cogeco ont réclamé une place dans le
marché du sans-fil au canada alors que
le crtc va tenir bientôt des audiences
publiques sur les services sans fil
l'entreprise de télécommunications
cogeco propose un projet dit hybride
avec nous pour en parler le pdg de
cogeco philippe jetté bonsoir monsieur
je t'ai répond soir ce film c'est le 18
février prochain que le crtc va amorcer
ses audiences publiques sur les services
sans fil vous proposer un modèle hybride
de proposer quoi exactement
je pense que ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que cogeco opère déjà au québec et en
ontario on dessert une zone d'à peu près
1.17 million de maisons dont la moitié
souscrivent déjà nos services internet
nous voulons ajouter le service sans fil
dans nos zones de couverture et je vous
dit un modèle hybride ça veut dire quoi
le modèle hybride et par opposition au
modèle qui est déjà en place et à dire
qui est limitée à certains jeux gros
joueurs de l'industrie
ça prend des fréquences pour opérer dans
le système actuel les fréquences sont
détenus par les joueurs existants
exactement remporté il ya plusieurs
types de fréquences les basses
fréquences y en a plus de disponibles
ils sont tous assignés aux grands
joueurs de l'industrie les moyennes
fréquences et en reste encore quelques
quelques unes et les autres fréquences
qui va devenir plus tard disponible mise
en enchère par industrie canada mais ça
prend les un jeu de une combinaison des
trois fréquences pour opérer un réseau
sans fil donc vous nous voulons à
pouvoir louer de la capacité sur le
réseau des plus grands au niveau des
fréquences qu'on a plus d'options
d'acquérir et le temps de construire nos
propres réseaux pour desservir nos
abonnés certes et c'est accepterait
parce que quelques années il y avait eu
des audiences aussi sur ce qu'on appelle
le rmv exploitants de réseau mobile
virtuel est certes et ce n était pas
aller de l'avant avec ce modèle là
pourquoi maintenant certains saisir et
oui et cela
bon le modèle le cadre réglementaire
actuel fonctionne assez bien pour les
grands centres urbains et je pense que
cela plusieurs années on était plutôt
concentrés sur les grands
de faire fonctionner le modèle d'ouvrir
la concurrence dans les grands centres
maintenant on est rendu dans les zones
un peu plus régionale voies rurales et
le modèle actuel ne fonctionne pas le
plusieurs petites villes encore vous
dire seulement un opérateur qui dessert
et on peut parler on ne peut pas parler
de concurrence avec juste un opérateur
c'est que donc pour introduire un
deuxième et un troisième donc du choix
pour les consommateurs ce qui va se
répercuter par une baisse de prix mais
aussi par de l'innovation différents
modèles de servir la clientèle la
capacité de s'abonner à des systèmes en
bouquets avec l'internet avec la
téléphonie tout ça ça va être ça va
devenir possible pour les régions et
pour donc si vous étiez doit par exemple
si vous aviez l'occasion d'offrir du
sans fil
est-ce que vos prix seraient plus bas
que bell telus rogers maintenant
évidemment va falloir voir où le crtc le
commencé à tester va faire évoluer son
cadre réglementaire mais si nous avions
la possibilité de louer de l'accès ou de
la capacité sur les réseaux des plus
grands et de combiner avec les réseaux
qu'on va mettre de l'avant qu'on va
construire
évidemment on pourrait monter une offre
de services intéressants pour nos
abonnés on a à peu près la moitié de nos
abonnés ont souscrit bleus de nos
maisons
un passé qui souscrivent à notre service
internet donc 850 mille clients sur les
1.7 million de maisons et on pourrait
facilement ajouter les services sans fil
pour ses abonnés lot cogeco vous êtes à
investir combien ça a pris qu'en 35 ans
pour les grands opérateurs à construire
leur réseau et ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que ça coûte extrêmement cher
double avantage de pouvoir louer de la
capacité est d'être capable de 2
d'après mme en avoir une opération
financière rentable balancer les
investissements et la croissance en même
temps que au fil des années on peut
agrandir nos zones de service et vous
voulez investir combien au total ça
c'est sûr que c'est une opération qui va
coûter du capital mais ça va être
investie sur plusieurs plus il ya
plusieurs années
encore une fois ci ont pris trente ans
pour les plus gros joueurs ça va nous
prendre une longue période pour combien
au total c'est il faut vraiment voir le
cadre réglementaire pour être capable de
déterminer mardi si on n'y a pas encore
de modèle quantifier puisque ça nous
prend le cadre réglementaire pour être
capable de quantifier nouveau nos
investissements la croissance aux états
unis
ça va assez bien vous avez récemment eu
l'approbation d'une acquisition d'un
fournisseur de réseau au connecticut
pour 63 millions de dollars canadiens
quelles sont vos intentions en sol
américain pour la suite des choses bon
notre croissance au canada et aux états
unis
premièrement c'est d'augmenter nos parts
de marché dans les territoires qu on
descend donc aux états unis au caire et
au canada on augmente la pénétration des
services internet de téléphonie et de
vidéo aux etats-unis où on a aussi un
autre vecteur de croissance qui sont les
acquisitions le marché est moins
consolidé il ya beaucoup plus de petits
opérateurs
au canada le marché beaucoup plus
consolidée donc on a grandi nos
territoires
quartier par quartier et on pourra et
avec la venue de notre nouveau service
iptv ajouter encore plus de
fonctionnalités du côté de nos services
vidéo et l'ajout des services sans fil
viendront complémenter notre portfolio
de services pour le marché canadien et
dans le médias la radio notamment vous
êtes propriétaires de stations de radio
dans les derniers résultats faisait
mention que les revenus publicité sont
plus faibles que par le passé ce que
vous voulez investir encore en radio ou
vous retirer tranquillement
on est très fiers de l'ajout de dix
stations de radio qu'on
réaliser maintenant blanc un an et nous
sommes le radiodiffuseur de plus un
privé le plus important au québec
c'est sûr que ce qui se passe dans le
domaine de la publicité avec les grands
joueurs américains facebook et les
autres créé plusieurs remous dans
l'industrie l'application inégale des
taxes de vente où j'aurai des choses
comme ça ça aide pour l'industrie
canadienne les gouvernements sont en
train de rectifier le tir
je les encourage à aller un petit peu
plus vite mais j'ai bon espoir que le
monde des médias écrits vidéo et radio
va tirer son épingle du jeu pourquoi
parce que ce sont des informations
locales et régionales que les médias de
la radio le gnr à chaque heure à chaque
à chaque jour pour les communautés dont
elle détient mais aussi le média de la
radio et d'un meilleur rassembleur
pourrait que ça permet aux communautés
de partager de l'information et de de
s'émanciper comme communauté
merci beaucoup monsieur gt merci merci